sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner die
begrüßt die gäste dieser sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich an den guten
abend karl lauterbach gestern noch der
gesundheitsminister der herzen freute
echter gesundheitsminister diese
nächsten wochen sind entscheidend sagen
sie was werden sie als erstes anders
machen ich werde jetzt mal erklären was
derzeit also notwendig ist und zwar wir
müssen die booster impfungen so stark
voranbringen noch erstimpfungen dass wir
also möglichst große teile der
bevölkerung geschützt haben bevor die
omikron variante kommt dass wir müssen
quasi vor der omicron war ja dann noch
die kurve bekommen das werde ich immer
wieder erklären und dabei auch in den
vordergrund stellen dass man nur mit
drei impfungen vor der omicron variante
wenn sie dann kommt wahrscheinlich gut
geschützt gut geschützt ist und dann
sagen sie dazu den satz wir werden das
schaffen sie wissen wie verhängnisvoll
so eine aussage ist das ist richtig also
das ist ein satz der also von dem ein
oder anderen oder von der einen oder
anderen bereich wurde aber ich versuche
einfach ehrlich zu sein ich glaube dass
wir das schaffen werden und werde alles
dafür tun meinte agnes strack zimmermann
ist bei uns fdp politikerin sie haben
frau statt zimmermann natürlich nicht
nur vernommen dass karl lauterbach jetzt
die politik im gesundheitsministerium in
den händen hat hätten sie da vor der
wahl noch die hände über dem kopf
zusammengeschlagen nein überhaupt nicht
das steht mir auch gar nicht zu ich habe
natürlich auch immer zugehört was herr
lauterbach sagt und in der tat hat er ja
oft oder andersrum selten daneben
gelegen und er ist jetzt hat er auch
vorhat geboren und der kanzler hat ja
gesagt ihr habt den gewollt ist habt ihr
ihn und insofern finde ich auch in
unserem interesse ich will das jetzt gar
nicht ins lächerliche ziehen wünsche ich
ihnen viel glück weil diese aufgabe ist
natürlich eine besondere
aber ich glaube es sind so viele fehler
gemacht worden dass wir jetzt in die
zukunft gucken und das macht natürlich
sehen erst mal zu gucken ob der
impfstoff von dem gesagt wird wir hätten
genug ob er auch da ist und wie ist die
logistik wie bekommen wir ihn jetzt eben
in die städte und länder ich glaube das
ist entscheidend und sie aus der
verteidigungspolitik sie haben sich über
general breuer und seine berufung sehr
gefreut aber was macht ein toller
general wenn er auf lehren im kissen
sitzt ja das wäre in der tat schlecht so
wenig so schlecht wie wenn er auf leeren
munitionskisten setzte also wir gehen
jetzt mal davon aus dass die kisten
hoffentlich gefüllt sind und
general breuer soll ja helfen sozusagen
die logistik in die hand zu bekommen hat
anderthalb jahre das thema begleitet und
ich habe mich gefreut weil ich ihn kenne
weil ich ihn für sehr fähiger achte und
ist einfach klug finde wenn jetzt die
fixen zusammenkommen denn das eine ist
der impfstoff das andere ist eben wie
probieren leute ran an den oberarm an
den oberarm letztendlich und ist es
möglich ebenso viel wie möglich menschen
zu erreichen bei uns ist viola prise man
sie ist nicht physisch hier am tisch
aber wir haben die tolle möglichkeit sie
wie er schalte aus göttingen bei uns in
der sendung zu haben frau prise man
physikerin beim max-planck-institut in
göttingen sie berechnen modelle für den
verlauf dieser pandemie ein
wissenschaftler wie karl lauterbach
jetzt an der spitze des
gesundheitsministeriums ist ja schon
eine garantie dafür dass ihre vorschläge
ihre warnungen nicht nur gehört sondern
auch umgesetzt wird
ich schätze karl lauterbach sehr dafür
dass er sich extrem gut in dieses thema
eingelesen hat das heißt wir müssen gar
nicht über die grundlagen sprechen dass
es klasse eine andere frage ist die
umsetzung das ist immer eine
güterabwägung das was wir typischerweise
machen ist verschiedene szenarien zu
berechnen da kann man sich dann
überlegen wie bereitet man sich zum
beispiel auf omikron vor da kann man
verschiedene alternativen auf den tisch
legen die güterabwägung und die
entscheidung ist selbstverständlich
weiterhin bei der politik in welche
richtung sie sich entscheidet und wie
sie natürlich auch die bevölkerung
mitnimmt und da werden wir noch viel
erfahren von dem was sie jüngst dazu
auch taten und berechnet haben timo
hildebrand ist bei uns
chefkorrespondentin derzeit frau
hildebrandt sie haben in einem artikel
diese woche karl lauterbach eine
gesundheitspolitische wundertüte genannt
warum naja steckt fehlen ihm drin steckt
ein gesundheitsexperte drin steckt ein
epidemiologe drin es steckt ein
parlamentarier in der ein
gesetzesvorhaben seit vielen vielen
jahrzehnten
beteiligt ist und im grunde sie haben es
auch schon anklingen dass er ist der
erste direkt gewählte minister muss man
sagen
viele waren also bei vielen ministern in
diesem kabinett ist es ja denkbar
gewesen dass sie auch andere posten
bekleiden so ist zum beispiel cem
özdemir in die landwirtschaft geraten
und bei ihm ist es aber eigentlich nicht
denkbar dass er irgendwas anderes machen
würde und umgekehrt war es am ende auch
gar nicht mehr vorstellbar dass
irgendein anderer dieses amt bekleiden
würde und darum ist er jetzt da und das
macht ihn glaube ich zu einer und
gleichzeitig ist er natürlich im zentrum
dieser riesigen krise die auch über wohl
und wehe der ampel regierung entscheiden
wird und dann ist da natürlich in einer
besonders unsere lage und er bringt
vieles dafür mit und es ist auch ein
interessantes experiment haben sie
gesagt zu sehen wie jemand der so sehr
fachwissenschaftler ist daneben auch so
ein ministerium managed wir sind bei
tobias hans über den wir uns genauso
freuen ministerpräsidenten des
saarlandes herr hans die politik der
union ist jetzt sehr viele positionen
logischerweise und sehr viel schimpfen
auf diese frisch gewählte ampel zu spät
dauert alles zu lange
hätten täte der union denken sie ein
bisschen mehr selbstkritik ganz gut in
anbetracht echter lage in der wir jetzt
und ich würde erstmal bevor ich darauf
antworte ebenfalls karl lauterbach
gratulieren zu seinem neuen amt ist
eines der wichtigsten ämter die wir im
moment in der bundesrepublik deutschland
haben und ich möchte mit ihm so gut
zusammenarbeiten wie auch mit den
bisherigen gesundheitsminister ich habe
da keinen zweifel daran dass es gelingt
ich will dass er erfolg hat vor allem
natürlich in der bekämpfung der pandemie
und ich sage auch mal an dieser stelle
zumindest mal für meine person auch zu
ich werde nicht gleich auf ihm rumhacken
auch nicht wenn vielleicht mal ein
fehler passiert ich glaube dafür ist die
lage zu ernst und deswegen muss aus
meiner sicht eine oppositionspolitik
auch eine konstruktive politik sein und
deswegen kann ich nur sagen aus sicht
der unions geführten länder reichen wir
da der neuen bundesregierung auch die
hand wir wollen das was geschieht und
ich glaube wenn man da auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz schaut als frank
zimmermann und ich das letzte mal
zusammen saßen hatte so war es eben noch
nicht so weit wie heute das was morgen
vorgelegt wird glaube ich bringt uns
wirklich weiter sie erinnern sich aber
daran dass tatsächlich diese epidemische
notlage von jens spahn abgesagt wurde
und dass die ministerpräsidenten auch
erst mal zugestimmt haben dass die lage
aus läuft also ja selbstverständlich wir
haben diese lage damals anders
eingeschätzt wir haben sie falsch
eingeschätzt und ich glaube wenn man
sich jetzt anschaut was omikron
möglicherweise nochmal anrichten wird in
diesem land halte ich es nach wie vor
für sehr wichtig dass wir den vollen
instrumentenkasten haben und dass wir
eben auch einen so genannten no
schutzschalter haben für den fall dass
diese variante überhand nimmt und sich
als gefährlicher erweist als die derzeit
vorherrschende delta variante wir müssen
wachsam eine neue virus mutation
versetzt nicht nur diesen tisch sondern
die welt in echte sorge sie heißt ami
konnte
schlechte nachrichten mitten in der
vierten welle
ab januar werden wir mit ronny krohn in
deutschland ein problem haben bis sommer
ein
erstes forschungsergebnis ist
ernüchternd bei doppelt geimpften egal
mit welchem impfstoff gibt es nach sechs
monaten keinen schutz mehr vor einer
infektion mit omikron
drei monate nachdem boostern mit bayern
tag liegt der schutz gegen die neue
mutante lediglich bei 25 prozent im
vergleich die wirksamkeit gegen delta 95
prozent
völlig unklar bislang ob aktuelle
impfstoffe schwere omikron verläufe
verhindern ein hoffnungsschimmer
vielleicht aber dafür müsste es genug
impfstoff geben fordern die kassen ärzte
der bund kann die von den praxen und
auch vom öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
angeforderten impfstoffmengen nicht
liefern
herr lauterbach sie haben schon gesagt
nur durch pusten sind wir am ende vor
nikon wirklich geschützt und auch jetzt
wirklich geschützt hat ihnen ihr
vorgänger genug impfstoff hinterlassen
also für dieses jahr auf jeden fall das
habe ich sehr präzise geprüft bin sie
wollten erst mal noch mal eine inventur
machen die inventur die jetzt kommt die
betrifft das nächste jahr erkennen dass
die wird morgen stattfinden da werden
wir mit vollbesetzung also im haus
möglich also jeden standen herum drehen
aber ich habe für die war das ja
notdürftiges ich bin relativ schnell ins
ministerium gekommen und also ab sofort
die arbeit aufnehmen noch vor der
vereidigung
aber ja er kann jetzt schon mal sagen
also bis zum jahresende haben wir genug
geben stunden 30 millionen bis
weihnachten olaf scholz versprochen sie
versprochen die genau dass es werden
mehr das problem sein das wir haben
bisher 14,5 millionen also für impfungen
vorgenommen es fehlt somit noch die
hälfte bis weihnachten also haben wir
zwar noch so etwas wieder ein bisschen
luft aber es kann durchaus sagen dass
wir die 30 millionen nachher nicht
schaffen das läge aber dann nicht an der
impfstoff menge die wir haben sondern ob
genug verfahren ist wortsinn wird
gekämpft und wir haben jetzt gestern
also eine neben free kocht gab von 1,1
millionen impfungen poster und
erstimpfungen zusammen 90 prozent
booster impfung in der sehr simpel das
ist extrem respekt habe so schnell im
moment was die booster impfung angeht in
europa niemand und also was ich hat
versuchen wir herauszufinden was ist die
lage für die nächsten monate war
christian drosten hat recht wir werden
also über die nächsten monate
schwierigkeiten bekommen wir müssen
daher ist uns die 30 millionen impfungen
gelingen sind wir damit überhaupt nicht
da wo wir hin müssen und daher brauchen
wir deutlich mehr impfstoff noch und da
wird eine bilanz gezogen ich bin aber
auch mit den herstellern im direkten
kontakt um also her um ihren stoff zu
besorgen und ich bin auch schon
dahingehend also in kontakt wenn es
einen neuen impfstoff gibt
mikronährstoffen den ersten mal den
angepassten angepassten werden wir den
auch bekommen ich warte gar nicht ab du
bist wir also einmal an diesen punkt
gekommen sind sondern ich gehe wirklich
in die beschaffung china schon jetzt
schon jetzt bestimmt wieder mit der
europäischen union oder alles also mit
der gleichen union auch aber es finden
auch bilaterale gespräche statt kommen
wir noch dazu wir wollen viola prise man
fragen vor prise man sollte nikon
tatsächlich das tun was viele sagen
nämlich geimpfte anstecken und eine
sogenannte escape mutation seien wären
dann die ungeimpften immer noch die
besonders sorgen machen de gruppe oder
während es irgendwann nicht auch die nur
doppelt geimpften
ja das ist eine gute frage wir wissen
inzwischen relativ gut dass am nikon
deutlich ansteckender ist das bedeutet
ist breitet sich sehr schnell aus wir
sehen in den anderen ländern dass sich
die fallzahlen vervierfachen jede woche
also die verdopplung zeit ist etwa bei
drei tagen vier tag manchmal sogar
schneller das kann natürlich verlangsamt
werden über masken das kann verlangsamt
werden über kontakt beschränkungen wir
wissen ja im prinzip wie man diese
varianten ausbremst aber das ist die
ansteckung der teil über den wir sehr
wenig wissen bisher ist in die fans zu
schweren verläufen kommt und da ist
müssen wir jetzt einfach noch mal ein
bisschen daten abwarten und hoffen
natürlich sehr und das ist eher weniger
zu schweren verläufen braucht das
problem ist nur wenn dieser welle so
extrem steil ansteigt dann stehen
natürlich alle leute selbst wenn es nur
wenige sind im prinzip gleichzeitig vor
den türen eines krankenhauses und das
kann sehr schwierig werden und wir
können jetzt natürlich best case
szenarien durchrechnen wir können best
mögliche szenarien durchrechnen und
abschätzen ich denke wir sollten in
dieser situation uns auf all diese
szenarien vorbereiten damit wir dann
wenn das in zwei oder drei oder vier
wochen notwendig sein sollte vorbereitet
in diese situation rein kommen und nicht
wieder hinter die welle kommen wie
schnell kann das boostern von dem jetzt
alle reden die lage tatsächlich
verbessern und haben sie ihre modelle
frau prise man jetzt eigentlich schon
mit nikon gerechnet nein konnten sie
noch nicht in gänze
das wichtige und der wichtige faktor
dort ist wirklich wie gutes gegen den
schweren verlauf schützt zurzeit ist es
so dass bei der aktuellen immunisierung
ja etwa 0,6 prozent aller erkannten
infizierten auf den intensivstationen
müssen als wir haben hospitalisierung
rate davon 0,6 prozent wir hoffen extrem
dass diese hospitalisierung rate für
omicron niedriger ist gerade bei den
geimpften und das wird er natürlich oder
wie hoch die ist das bestimmt welche
belastungen die auf der intensivstation
erwarten der aber darum nur dein
verhältnis zu geben wir bräuchten
wahrscheinlich was in richtung von nur
0,1 prozent der infizierten die auf
intensivstationen müssen damit wir mit
ach und krach durch kommen das ist eine
sechsfache reduktion das ist relativ
viel das liegt einfach daran dass wenn
diese werte kommt sie sehr schnell kommt
und die person alle auf einmal kommen
dass es dann in der kurzen zeit in
dieser kurzen zeit lässt sich das extrem
schwer bewältigen und das ist sehr hoch
war dass es so ist dass wir nur milde
verläufe haben und das wissen wir noch
nicht vollstreckt immer man es gibt böse
zungen sagen die haltung der liberalen
mutierte in dieser sache so schnell wie
das virus wie kommen die liberalen wie
kommt die fdp tatsächlich auch politisch
wieder vor die welle um mal in diesem
bild zu bleiben ist nikon da vielleicht
eine hilfe um auch gesichtswahrend
rauszukommen aus einem zu spät wir haben
ja in den letzten monaten darüber
diskutiert und jeder wurde gerade im
wahlkampf gefragt ich nehme an sie
spielen auf eine mögliche impfpflicht
hin
dass man sich das nicht vorstellen
können aber das ist wie wenn es brennt
und sie haben einen kleinen schlauch und
plötzlich läuft das wird das vorher
nicht gelöscht sondern es wird deutlich
stärker nehmen sie auch in größeren
schlau was ich damit sagen will wir
haben eine lage die wir wahrnehmen und
ich begrüße es ausdrücklich dass der
neue justizminister marco buschmann auch
ins spiel gebracht hat und das jetzt
auch so kommt dass jeder im bundestag
wenn wir darüber debattieren da sehr
differenziert debattieren wie weit wie
es eben schaffen dass sehr viele
menschen
herr lauterbach hat es ja gesagt geimpft
werden ich meinte gar nicht die
impfpflicht ich meinte natürlich die art
und weise wie die korona epidemische
lage für beendet erklärt wurde die
milderen maßnahmen
dass das infektionsschutzgesetz
irgendwie jetzt wieder also die kraft
der parlamente wieder zurück sollen
dafür kann man sich ja sehr einsetzen
aber es fehlt ja zusammen mit einer ex
also mit einem exponentiellen anstieg
der infektionszahlen
habe ich sie gar falsch verstanden ich
es ging ja darum dass die parlamente
beteiligt werden gerade wenn es um
eingriffe in persönliche rechte geht und
das war vor dieser oder das alte gesetz
hat es nicht ermöglicht da konnte eine
in diesem fall die kanzlerin mit
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsidenten
sich zusammensetzen ist ein gremium das
die verfassung gar nicht vorsieht und
konnte sagen so ab morgen reist ihr
nicht oder reis doch oder macht jenes
und dieses und das geht natürlich nicht
sondern ist kann erstens muss es in den
bundestag und was viel wichtiger ist
durch die neuen regeln 2030 regeln haben
die länder alle möglichkeiten jetzt
lokal zu entscheiden was passiert und
das ist deswegen wichtig weil wenn sie
instanzen in sachsen thüringen und
bayern haben die völlig anders ist als
zb in norddeutschland das eben die
ministerpräsidenten die möglichkeit
haben dann entsprechend zu entscheiden
deswegen haben wir es geht immer um
diese überschrift natürlich haben wir
eine epidemische lage aber das
handwerkzeug ist ein anderer und man
muss gerade in großen schweren krisen
muss man immer auch im auge behalten wie
geht man mit den rechten der menschen
und deswegen finde ich was das betrifft
sind wir vor der welle aber wir sind in
der tat nicht impft technik vor der
welle und das ist ja jetzt unser ansehen
dass wir das gemeinsam so und haben all
diese prozesse hier wahnsinnig viel zeit
gekostet und sie sind eben parallel
gelaufen zu einer eklatanten
gesundheitspolitischen lage weil im
grunde ja klar war dass man sich diese
juristische debatte mit einer nun schon
zwei mal drei mal verschärft in einem
verteiler verschafften
infektionsschutzgesetz eigentlich gerade
nicht so richtig leisten wir fragen mal
die sich des ministerpräsidenten aus der
sicht eines ministerpräsidenten
nun ist es ja gerade wieder richtig
wichtig dass man sich mit den
ministerpräsidenten trifft und es muss
zum dritten mal ein
infektionsschutzgesetz erweitert werden
wird das alles noch rechtzeitig genug
geschehen also haben ganz ohne frage
zeit verloren wir hätten müssen früher
zusammen kommen und ich will auch gar
nicht widersprechen dass die runde der
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten nicht in der
verfassung steht als solches organ aber
es hat eben in der pandemie mehrfach
geholfen wenn die mps zusammengekommen
sind mit der damaligen bundesregierung
dass sich das verhalten der menschen
auch geändert hat weil wenn alle
regierungschefs zusammenkommen und sagen
es muss sich eingeschränkt werden und
dann führt das alleine schon dazu dass
die menschen sich ein stück weit
zurücknehmen und ich glaube die
besprechung heute mit der neuen
bundesregierung die einen tag im amt ist
die hat noch mal was bewirkt weil
deutlich geworden ist es gibt unisono
unter allen länderchefs eine an
erkenntnis dass wir mit omikron eine
völlig neue situation bekommen die uns
dazu veranlassen muss im nächsten jahr
vorbereitet zu sein und das bedeutet zu
erlauben weil was eben jetzt nicht
einfach möglich ist das ist eine ganz
zentrales thema das wir ein komplettes
lockdown in deutschland machen und vor
allen dingen die schulen fließen und jan
sie wissen dass wir natürlich das große
gesundheitliche probleme haben aber wir
haben das große soziale problem dass wir
kinder fast ein jahr lang nicht beschult
haben dass junge familien home office
und homeschooling gemacht haben dass wir
kinder schule ist ja ein lernort aber es
ist noch ein sozialer ort war auch
auffälligkeiten eben benannt wäre und
deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass das
gesetz geändert wurde dass man eben
nicht einfach mal so locker die schulen
schließt sondern dass das eben in der
balance sein muss und insofern
will ich ihnen jetzt gar nicht in diese
alte diskussion verfallen weil wir
wirklich nach vorne gucken müssen aber
was eben nicht geht dass nach einem
treffen am nächsten morgen aufgewacht
wird und gesagt wird so jetzt machen nun
werden alle schulen nicht ehrlich gesagt
also ganz ehrlich gesagt es war ja nie
so also ich glaube nach einer mpk haben
wir ja nicht nur aus der mpk sieben
verschiedene meinungen gehört also das
bild ist ja auch ein irgendwie sehr
honoriges was bezeichnet wird es sind ja
irgendwie hinterher acht verschiedene
meinungen dann auch als ergebnis aus
dieser mpk rausgegangen und auch sie
herr hans wissen aus eigener erfahrung
ich glaube die kanzlerin hat sie sogar
öffentlich mal gerüffelt dafür dass sie
ganz vorne beim öffnen sein wollten im
april um jetzt relativ zügig wieder
zuzumachen und zu merken das ist eben
schwer ist und modell durchzuhalten wenn
runden drumherum viel infektion ist was
sagen sie denn jetzt ihren menschen sie
sagen wir haben uns geirrt oder also
erst mal haben wir damals im saarland
das getan was alle gemacht haben dann
mit etwas zeit nicht im nachklapp wir
haben aktivitäten von drinnen nach
draußen verlagert das war auch das
richtig und wir haben angefangen sehr
viel zu testen das was heute standard
ist in ganz deutschland und test
gestützte modelle die helfen eben auch
dunkelziffern zu entdecken wir testen im
moment wieder über 400.000 menschen pro
woche was absoluter spitzenwert ist
sicherlich und damit kann man dazu
beitragen dass eben auch verborgene
infektionen erkannt werden insofern war
das immer nur ein modell was sagt soviel
einschränkung wie nötig aber so viel
freiheit wie möglich und das kannte
nicht nur lockerung sondern das kannte
eben auch einschränkungen und jetzt
müssen wir in die einschränkung geht es
völlig unbestritten und frau stark
zimmermann wir wollen keine schulen
schließen aber was wichtig ist oder es
wichtig ist ist dass länder wie sachsen
oder bayern mit einer impfquote die
einfach nur entsetzlich niedrig ist dass
die trotzdem auch möglichkeiten in der
hand haben da wo es ganz besonders stark
betroffen ist zu handeln und wenn das
gesetz so gut gewesen wäre dass man es
jetzt nicht ändern also ich glaube das
ist ja auf einem guten weg deswegen will
ich gar nicht jetzt mit ihnen an dieser
stelle streit nicht ein größeres morgen
kommt hilft uns hilft und das wird auch
durchs parlament gehen fragen wir gleich
noch mal in richtung gesundheitsminister
im saarland wollen und müssen sich jetzt
auch boostern aber wie erklären sie das
ihren menschen dass da jetzt eben dieser
impfstoff und wenn doch mal gepostet
wird das wir aber eigentlich vielleicht
im februar märz schon einen anderen
impfen müssten wird es noch verstanden
von den saarländern also erst mal
scheint es zu funktionieren wir sind bei
den auffrischungsimpfungen auf dem
spitzenplatz deutschlandweit wir haben
23,6 prozent der menschen jetzt schon
gebucht wir haben übrigen damit
angefangen bevor die stiko das empfohlen
hat in den altenhilfeeinrichtungen haben
im november schon alle durch gehabt und
es zeigt dass das angenommen wird wir
sind ja ganz vorne bei der impfquote
auch deutschlandweit wichtig ist dass
wir den menschen klar machen egal jetzt
erstmal welcher impfstoff impfstoffe und
impfung und vor allem die auffrischung
hilft dabei schwerwiegende erkrankung zu
verhindern so oder so und wenn man heute
mal schauen dass wir trotz viel zu hohen
instanzen ich will das gar nicht
irgendwie schön reden wir sind viel zu
hohe instanzen dass wir trotzdem die
schulen offen haben und selbst da wenn
sie vielleicht geschlossen werden müssen
ist die möglichkeit da das digitaler
unterricht stattfinden kann wir haben
erhebliche fortschritte gemacht und die
haben wir vor allem gemacht weil so
viele menschen bereit waren sich impfen
so das muss man einfach mal danke sagen
denen die sich am impfen lassen und
denen die das möglich gemacht haben und
das durchgeführte frau hildebrandt es
gibt einen löchrigen löchrigen
impfschutz der ist eben nicht sicher und
das versprechen dass wir uns zweimal
impfen lassen und dann ist der bürger
sicher ist schon mal nicht eingetroffen
und es gibt die unsicherheit über die
schwere einer erkrankung wenn wir dann
tatsächlich jetzt mit dieser mutation
hantieren müssen im grunde ist das eine
stunde null für die pandemie
fragezeichen und wie erklärt man das den
menschen in diesem land ein bisschen ich
glaube dass wichtige heute bei der runde
der ministerpräsidenten
war dass danach der
nicht so leicht überleben kanzler stolz
gesagt hat wir werden uns noch öfter
impfen lassen müssen und wir müssen
jetzt darüber streiten ob das zwei- oder
dreimal ist immer das signal das erste
signal bei die impfpflicht wird kommen
muss ja sagen solange es keine
impfpflicht gibt es ist eine absolut
legitime entscheidung sich auch nicht
irgendwann zu lassen und das für sich so
zu priorisieren dass man es nicht macht
damit ist klargestellt jetzt wird es
eine impfpflicht geben und das ist dann
keine legitime entscheidung mehr egal
wie man dazu steht es ist damit eine
klarheit geschaffen und ich glaube es
ist auch ein wichtiges signal zu sagen
es wird nicht aufhören denn das war ja
im prinzip die idee deswegen haben ja
diese ganzen dieses ganze nachlassen
eingesetzt weil wir abgesehen davon dass
es sehr viele strategie und ziel wechsel
gab irgendwann sich so der eindruck
eingestellt hat wenn es dann wenn wir
dann alle geimpft sind dann ist es gut
dann sind wir durch und dann war klar
wenn wir alle zweimal geimpft sind dann
klar wir werden vielleicht noch mal
auffrischen müssen aber es war im
prinzip ist stand immer so im raum wir
können dann im prinzip die tische
zusammenräumen in den impfzentren wir
können dann einpacken die sache ist
angelaufen und das fand ich heute ein
wichtiges signal das mal klar gestellt
worden ist so ist das nicht wir werden
sehr sehr lange noch in diesem zustand
dieser diese stand by bleiben müssen wo
man sozusagen rauf und runter abend und
einsatz wird aber würden sie sagen wir
sind in einer situation wo auch noch ein
bisschen die glücks waage entscheidet ob
und wie sehr wir getroffen werden nein
ich glaube das hängt davon habe ich
schnell wir sind also immer muss er die
situation konkret beschreiben so dass
die bürger oder zuschauer ein gefühl
davon bekommen was wir können dass ich
jetzt entwickeln was ist denn überhaupt
die gefahren mit dem mikro und so weiter
und so fort wir haben also je nach
bundesland irgendwo zwischen 20 bis 23
prozent
geimpfte die schon die dritte impfung
haben die anderen also die noch nicht
die dritte impfung haben das ist was wir
derzeit annehmen müssen sind nicht also
gefühl ständig geschützte sie heißt es
nicht und sagen sind gar nicht geschützt
gegen die infektionen mit der umgekommen
da muss man es auch versuchen
einigermaßen ehrlich zu sagen werden die
daten jetzt anders auskommen dann haben
wir glück aber die daten die es derzeit
gebe auch südafrika die daten von sandra
zeck die saar antwort insgesamt genau
dass zwei jungen klein schutz genau und
die daten insbesondere von bayern texte
etwas sind ja jeweils also modell daten
also mit virus also touren kulturen
genau die nicht genau den also virus
entsprechen aber sehr zuverlässig sind
die besten dieser susanne experimente
macht bei und text selbst und die
ergebnisse selbst lassen auch vermuten
die doppelt geimpften sind
wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger was die
ansteckung angeht das ist noch nicht die
krankheit aber was die ansteckung angeht
sind die mehr oder weniger wenig oder
gar nicht geschützt das bedeutet wenn
das jetzt schnell kommt weil die booster
impfungen nicht da sind was wird
passieren
na dann werden natürlich mehr oder
weniger und kurzes derzeit alle
ungeimpften infiziert weil wenn die
geimpften die zweimal geimpft sich
infizieren dann lockt jetzt weiter durch
in die umkämpften union gelten werden
dann was frau triesmann gesagt hat deren
arbeite ich sehr schätze dieser hinsicht
also auch hoch relevant ist das läuft
dann in die umkämpften rein und dann
also sind dann wären die ungenutzten in
sehr kurzer zeit schwer erkranken daher
müssen wir den menschen das konkret
erklären was könnte hier passieren es
könnte sein dass die omikron variante
bei den geimpften
infektionen macht die dann zum schluss
bei den ungeimpften schwere krankheit
machen das ist sozusagen die situation
dreifach geimpfter gehen wahrscheinlich
relativ gut durch geimpfte gehen
wahrscheinlich so durch dass sie auf
jeden fall sich infizieren können aber
möglicherweise nicht schwer erkranken
und die ungeimpften die trifft es dann
aber wirklich ganz hart und das ist also
was wir derzeit also vermuten ist dem
kann man nur begegnen und in dem man
diese mittlere gruppe so schnell wie
möglich mit der booster impfung versorgt
wie möglich und daran arbeiten wir das
war ja auch wenn ich möchte hier nicht
aus den details der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz berichten
aber ich glaube das können wir hier
offen sagt sieht man das war ja ein
schwerpunkt auf unser erst war ja auch
ein schwerpunkt unserer debatte heute
und ich stimme ihnen zu dass wir in
diese richtung gehen herr lauterbach
erschien bei untergründe er hat gesagt
dass er ungefähr 90 bis 100 tage
brauchen wird um diese angereicherte
neue
impfstoff variante herzustellen
sie sagen
das ist zu schaffen dann auch
rechtzeitig genug diese vielen millionen
impfungen zu bestellen die wir von
dieser
aufgefrischten neuen impfungen bräuchten
bestellen ja also man muss hier
folgendes stehen also herr sahin
schreibt korrekt ähnlich wird das auch
bei moderner beschrieben was in dieser
hinsicht unsere top impfstoffe sind in
drei monaten könnten wenn die
zulassungsverfahren sehr schnell gehen
könnten diese impfstoff schon produziert
werden aber das volumen was wir brauchen
das ist damit noch nicht abgesichert
weil wenn der neue wenn die neue
variante da ist dann würde es
bestellungen für diesen impfstoff aus
der ganzen welt die ganze welt wie das
wird dann also wird es nicht so sein
dass wir da also und daher darf man den
alten stoff nicht unterschätzen weil wir
in der booster impfung also einen guten
schutz bietet aber wir haben wir müssen
natürlich sicherstellen das habe ich
heute noch im hause geprüft das hier
bestellungen also hat unsere
bestellungen automatisch auf den neuen
impfstoff übergeben genau wenn eine neue
variante kommt so und ein media abgesägt
und wenn die dann aber als sie verzeihen
die frage wenn wir dann mit der
zulassung durch die stiko auch noch mal
100 tage brauchen dann wäre das eher
unglücklich die stiko gibt ja nur eine
empfehlung und ich bin ganz sicher der
druck wird spürbar sein politischer
druck auf dich deko verbietet sich das
ist ein unabhängiges organ ist haben sie
vorhin schon erklären aber da ist
dann sehr schnell sich bewegen wird es
melden sich ja frau schwesig aus
mecklenburg vorpommern herr weil es
beschweren sich ministerpräsident weil
wir es ende oktober gesagt haben es wäre
gut über die stiko über 70-jährige zu
boostern ende oktober ja es ist eine
unglückliche also
austeilung der also gibson über die
daten also ich sag jetzt einfach wie ich
das wissenschaftler sehe dass keine
kritik an der stiko sondern richtig
macht ihre arbeit aber es gab
wissenschaft nur die waren der meinung
dass die booster impfung auch in
jüngeren jahrgängen sozusagen
ja ihren wert hätte und die stiko hatte
entschieden dass damit haben wir gelebt
aber nicht dass dort sie da haben wir
ein bisschen zeit möglicherweise
verloren aber hier sind wir eben in
einem galopp und ich hatte eben mir
schon darauf hingewiesen diese 30
millionen das werden wir möglicherweise
noch schaffen das würde wären dann nicht
am impfstoff legen sondern ob das eben
der pop wie das tempo haben da ist ja
jetzt austauschen können wir auch machen
wenn die immer zulassung da ist das ist
ja auch wichtig dafür auch im cent genau
so ist es genauso und die ehemann
zulassung ist da und auf die haben wir
uns nur nicht von anfang an getraut dann
ausschließlich zu hören und haben auf
die stiko hatte war wir haben in den
altenhilfeeinrichtungen angebot gemacht
für die über 70-jährigen das ist gut
angenommen worden und das ergebnis war
dass hier keine infektion der kaum
infektionen gesehen haben in den
altenhilfeeinrichtung also man kann da
schon auch ein paar dinge in die
richtige richtung entwickeln ohne den
finger auf andere zu erheben wiesemann
wir verstehen jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen präzise wie die situation ist
wir verstehen das auch in anderen
ländern wenigstens habe ich das gelesen
die sogar besser stehen mit dem impfen
es ähnliche probleme gibt das heißt das
impfen hilft zwar aber es ist nicht das
einzige was hilft ist dass ihr
notschalter von dem sie sprechen
wir sehen an anderen ländern gerade die
die noch eine höhere impfquote haben
gerade bei den älteren dass dort die
hospitalisierung natürlich auch
entsprechend niedriger ist das ist dass
eine impfung hilft ich glaube das ist
unstrittig aber die ich möchte ganz klar
weg von dieser polarisierung impfen
hilft hilft nicht zu der frage wie gut
hilft es unter welchen umständen und wie
kann man diesen schutz im 2 auch noch
verbessern also weg von der
polarisierung ist da ganz man kann sagen
impfen ins boot wenn ich ihn aber es ist
nicht ausreichend
zusätzlich zum impfen schlagen wir vor
dass man sich gedanken machen sollte
über ein worst case ich bin mir leider
als mathelehrerin immer wieder die
überbringerin der schlechten nachrichten
das ist was was ich total gerne mache
mir geht es einmal hier auch in diesem
fall von omikron wo wir so wenig über
die schweren verläufe bisher wissen mir
geht es darum dass wir uns gedanken
machen was machen wir im letzten fall
und es muss ja nicht meckern sein das
kann ja auch eine andere variante sein
dass man sich auch die möglichkeiten
offen lässt in dem in diesen blöden fall
dass die fallzahlen sehr schnell steigen
und die schweren verläufe doch höher
sind als man sich das wünschen würde
dass man dann schnell und zügig und
wirklich früh genug reagiert wir wissen
aus der ganzen vergangenen pandemien das
schnell sein und das auch im zweifel
hart durchgreifen sehr viel ärger sehr
viel langfristigen ärger sparen kann ich
glaube niemand von uns möchte wieder so
einen ewigen lockdown light oder mitte
wie wir im letzten winter hatten das ist
richtig und wenn sie von diesem
notschalter sprechen frau prise man dann
schalten wir was zusätzlich ab sie reden
dann also von regionalen lockt downs
abhängig von instanzen und
hospitalisierung raten
wir können bei varianten wie zum
beispiel omikron nicht lokal denken
omikron ist was das ist nicht nur für
ein bundesland oder eine region das ist
für deutschland für europa für die ganze
welt ein problem und insofern müssen wir
anfangen mindestens mal europaweit zu
denken dass das eine und das andere ist
zu sagen und das zeigen die modelle und
das zeigen die berechnungen absolut klar
wenn ich es schaffe innerhalb von kurzer
zeit den erwert zum beispiel richtung 07
zu senken dann halbiert die fallzahlen
innerhalb von der woche er schaffe ich
nur den 0,9 weil ich eben kompromisse
eingehen dann brauche ich für das ganzen
monat und dann ist es eine güterabwägung
zu fragen mache ich sage ich mal zwei
wochen alles was ich zu machen kann zu
wie der güterabwägung was da alles ist
und schafft der wert von 0,7 zu
erreichen habt ihr also die halbierung
in den zwei wochen zwei mal hinbekommen
und schafft dadurch eine entlastung das
ist keine lösung das ist eine entlastung
oder mache ich eben wieder nur ein
halben lockdown und dann kriege ich
vielleicht mehr wert von 1 und ich habe
diese seitwärtsbewegungen dem zweifelt
ewig dauern kann das ist eine überlegung
die man ganz klar stellen sollte und wir
denken aus der modellierung und auch aus
den theoretischen überlegungen das kurz
und hart durchgreifen wesentlich weniger
belastungen langfristig bringen als eben
diese halben lockt uns diese halben
logins und nun ist ja wieder was
interessantes passiert herr hand sie
setzen im saarland in vielen anderen
ländern logischerweise auch aber sie
auch auf zweig sie möchten für geimpfte
und genesene so lange wie möglich ein
besonderes also ein normales leben
erhalten und jetzt verstehen wir aber
das geimpft und genesen morgen ja heißt
man muss schon gepostet sei das heißt
der geimpfte von morgen ist der drei mal
geimpft das heißt auch dass sie für die
anderen die noch nicht gebucht sind die
gleichen einschränkungen verfügen müssen
also erst mal ist es ja so dass wir eine
klare arbeitsanweisung haben von dem was
jetzt gerade noch einmal dargestellt
worden ist und das bedeutet wir müssen
die aktuelle del-tabelle
bremsen und wir haben ja auch schon
delta falsch eingeschätzt da haben wir
einiges gelernt selbst in portugal mit
hoher impfquote sieht mehr ist das jetzt
kommt deswegen müssen wir diese welle
bremsen dazu glaube ich ist es wichtig
dass man eine klare botschaft sendet den
ungeimpften ihr seid jetzt raus und aus
dem gesellschaftlichen leben deswegen
machen wir konsequent zweig machen aber
dort wo keine maske getragen werden kann
im saarland auch zweig plus und sagen
dort wer nicht gepostet ist der kann
auch nicht ohne test irgendwo ins
restaurant maske unternehmen oder ins
fitnessstudio und ja wir glauben dass
wir damit es schaffen können die welle
zu brechen aber wenn wir merken das
gelingt uns nicht rechtzeitig und da bin
ich noch mal völlig bei frau briesemann
dann können wir nicht in die kommende
omikron welle und sie wird kommen die
menschen spüren dass da draußen da muss
man jetzt gar nicht so tun als würde
sind vorbereitet werden und die muss man
nicht mehr vorbereiten das weiß jeder
wenn es uns nicht gelingt diese welle zu
brechen durch reduktion von kontakten
übrigen auch von geimpften personen
deswegen hatte ich das für ganz wichtig
dass wir heute auch in der mpk noch mal
gesagt haben weihnachten mit selbst wenn
man geimpft mit 50 60 leuten zu hause
nach und nach dass das wird nicht
funktionieren
damit schaffen wir das nicht und wenn
wir das nicht hinbekommen und dann wird
es eben auch noch mal harte maßnahmen
geben müssen wo ich jetzt schon mal sage
ich hoffe dass das nicht wieder die
kinder und jugendlichen als allererstes
trifft und man muss auch wissen wenn das
kommt zerstört man wieder existenzen
deswegen muss vorher die frage geklärt
sein wie helfe ich denjenigen gehört ich
habe meine kommen zum nächste frage an
frau stark zimmermann gewesen es gibt
schon genug gastwirte frau steckte man
die sagen am liebsten wäre mir es wäre
wieder zu weil mein restaurant ist offen
aber keiner kommt ist eigentlich der
schleichende tod dann kann man auch
sagen wir machen lieber zu und wir
machen wie frau prise man sagt hat zu
und haben ein solches langes dahin
siechen irgendwie nie wieder zu ertragen
würden sie sagen
schnell muss hilfe und schnell muss eine
entscheidung her also erstmal muss
schnell gepustet werden das angebot
gemacht werden das stelle die die
zweimal geimpft sind wollen ja ein
drittes mal es probleme sind ja nicht
die zweimal und das dritte mal wollen
sondern die die gar nicht wollen also
insofern ist jetzt die bundesrepublik
aufgefordert die länder und der bund
noch mal den impfstoff zu beschaffen
rechtzeitig zu beschaffen so fern ist
gut dass sie schon weiterdenken auf die
nächste möglichkeit also das angebot
muss erstmal geschaffen werden es ist
nicht so dass die restaurants alle leer
sind das ist nicht so entscheidend
ist dass zwei gegner ist das auch
kontrolliert wird erst jetzt wird
wirklich kontrolliert ich habe das hier
in berlin erlebt er wird man sagte man
ja ja wird schon stimmen sondern dass
man auch wenn man einen kennt kontrolle
und auch den personalausweis das ist das
erste dann wären die drei impfungen
zeigen dass man dann zeigt und dass man
dann an dem platz die maske an natürlich
ist das nicht der ganz harter weg aber
was passiert denn wenn wir jetzt die
restaurants schließen kann ich ihnen
genau sagen was dann passiert sieht man
übrigens in bayern schon wo das ja
früher schluss ist gehen die leute nach
hause und dann passiert etwas man sie
sagt gerade 60 leute an weihnachten also
ich habe schon eine große familie aber
60 leute an weihnachten fertig doch
jetzt auch an drei teilen muss ich sagen
nein also wir wollen jetzt die liebe zur
familie nicht übertreiben aber 60 ist
schon stramm aber spaß beiseite
das wissen die leute ja dass das jetzt
nicht das exorbitant oder die das
riesige party wird aber wenn sie die
restaurants schließen werden die leute
zu hause oder bei freunden weiter feiern
und dann entzieht es sich jeder sozialen
kontrolle und was ich nicht möchte dass
der nachbar dann irgendwo anruft und
sagt also bei der familie müller
lüdenscheid sind glaube ich mehr als 20
leute das kann es gar nicht sagen ich
verstehe aus der wissenschaftlichen
sicht dass die die harte antwort
vernünftig wäre aber diese welt kann man
nicht nur wissenschaftlich betrachten
wir müssen sie auch sozial betrachten
deswegen glaube ich schon das sage ich
jetzt als nicht virologin dass man
trotzdem bei aller deutlichkeit einen
weg finden muss dieses gesellschaftliche
leben nicht völlig zum erliegen tricks
tun wir ja also wir haben ja zum
beispiel in restaurants zweig plus und
ich bin ja auch im kontakt mit den
gastronomen man muss aber schon sagen
das ist sehr reduziert was da an kommt
es gibt erhebliche umsatzeinbußen und
das greift er natürlich von den
restaurants auf den handel über man muss
es einfach wissen dass wir jetzt tun ist
definitiv das mildere mittel und ich
halte das auch für richtig ist damit zu
versuchen aber die existenzen leiden
natürlich auch darunter und deswegen ist
es wichtig alle alle leiden die einen
mehr die anderen weniger keine frage mir
war nur daran gelegen zu glauben wenn
man das alles schließt dass die menschen
dann komplett auf distanz gehen das
glaube ich im jahr 2 wir sind in drei
jahren drei wochen sind wir im jahr 2022
dann sind wir fast zwei jahre in der
pandemie und mir sagen wissenschaftler
eher lauter war vielleicht können sie
das bestätigen dass so eine pandemie gut
drei jahre gehen kann und ich möchte
nicht dass ich höre von depressionen
gerade von jungen menschen die das ich
nicht mehr treffen können das macht ja
was mit dieser gesellschaft die schon
deswegen sehe ich das zu begeben
unwissenschaftlich eben auch aus der
sozialen sich vor briesemann ich wollte
sie sind gleich noch mal daran ich
wollte ganz kurz karl lauterbach nochmal
zu unserer präzision fragen zweig heißt
geimpft und genesen das sind zukünftig
die geposteten dreifach geimpften und
was ist eigentlich mit den genießen die
sind dann einmal geimpft und müssen auch
noch wenigstens ein zweites mal geimpft
sein nur dass man das kapiert frank mit
dem letzten an die studienlage zu den
genesenen ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht abgeschlossen aber wir haben gute
gründe zu glauben leider muss ich sagen
und dass gerade die genesenen von der
oregon variante besonders hat also sich
sehr schnell infizieren die also
ursprünglichen daten aus südafrika die
überhaupt auf die omikron variante k
hingewiesen haben das waren also
mehrheitlich
erkrankte die ich schon vorher genesene
waren manchmal sogar schon doppelt
genießen sie hatten schon zwei andere
varianten hinter sich und dann ist die
omikron variante aber trotzdem da hinein
gekommen und hat die solid menschen
infizieren können somit wäre meine
vermutung auf der grundlage der bisher
publizierten daten auch in also vorab
veröffentlichungen von renommierten
gruppen dass also der genesenen status
uns nicht viel bringt bei der omicron
variante da muss dann schon mehr
dahinter sein da könnte man sich zum
beispiel vorstellen genießen und zwar
mal nein gesagt aber wie gesagt die
daten müssen ausgewertet werden das ist
nicht spruchreif ich wollte nur den
derzeitigen wissenschaftlichen stand
zusammenfassen und ich glaube dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt der zweig status für
diejenigen die beispielsweise also fünf
monate zurück also die zweite impfung
gab an mit der data variante das ist
durchaus noch respekt habe da ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
infiziert schon also deutlich erhöht
aber schwere krankheit nicht und der
impfschutz also den darf man da nicht
unterschätzen man darf auch nicht also
sagen mal in panik verfallen somit
werden wir was ich gut finde werden wir
die booster impfung nach fünf monaten
machen würden und nicht nach sechs dafür
spricht die wissenschaft gestartet hatte
märklin noch genau da bin ich aber
nichtsdestotrotz also dass wir aber
trotzdem sind diejenigen die nach fünf
monaten nach der impfung sind sind das
schon noch gut geschützte wolle da
fahren so hier sind nochmal frau prise
man bei der frage von frau strack
zimmermann kann man als dreifach geimpft
musterte ihn noch ins restaurant gehen
ist das etwas wo sie sagen ab dann und
dann sollten wir auch einen solchen gang
überlegt
den punkt den ich da in dieser
diskussion klarstellen wollte ist der
folgende es geht uns überhaupt nicht
darum dass wir sagen wir brauchen jetzt
irgendwie notschalter den ganz starken
locker und es kommt immer darauf an das
ziel zu formulieren wenn das ziel ist
die fallzahl schnell runter zu bringen
jetzt in der aktuellen situation klar
dann hilft mehr überproportional mehr
aber wenn das ziel ist einfach sage ich
mal am limit der intensivstation zu
bleiben dann kommen wir mit dem zweig
bis jetzt ist relativ gut durch und je
mehr gewusst hat ist dann könnte man
wenn man nur auf die eltern schauen
würde auch besser durchkommen wenn man
aber jetzt einfach kategorisch
ausschließt dass man auch diese härteren
maßnahmen macht so blöd sie sind so viel
dem wirkungen sie haben wenn man das
kategorisch ausschließt dann ist das ein
stück weit dem wunschdenken wir wissen
nicht ob es brauchen wir sollten uns
vorbereiten und ich möchte gerne
klarstellen dass es uns nicht darum geht
zu sagen wir müssen das jetzt machen uns
geht es ganz klar darum zu sagen dass
rechtlich und organisatorisch und
einfach von einem gedankenexperiment her
einmal vorzubereiten damit wir danach
nicht überrascht sind und wieder zu spät
sind und hinter der welle sind so und
das ist auch gut dass erst zum zweiten
mal sagen ich hoffe es haben jetzt alle
verstanden wir reden über die
impfpflicht und das machen wir
es war das zentrale versprechen von
anfang an wir wollen nämlich keine
impfpflicht einführen ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht es wird keine impfpflicht
gibt die bundesregierung hat sich ganz
klar darauf verständigt in diesem land
wird es zum einen keine impfpflicht
geben natürlich wissen wir alle dass
eine impfpflicht also nicht durchsetzbar
wir sind gegen die impfpflicht
jetzt kommt die kehrtwende
ich habe verschiedene argumente und die
geringe impfbereitschaft allerdings
nachdenklich gemacht die vorbereitungen
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht müssen
getroffen werden um so heftiger die
reaktionen auf den wortbruch wind auf
die mühlen von querdenkern freien
sachsen und afd die verschwörungs
ideologen fühlen sich voll bestätigt
sagt steffen augsburg vom deutschen
ethikrat
na ja das kann man ja schon sehen dass
die also glückstrahlend sagen wir haben
es doch immer gesagt den dürft ihr nicht
vertrauen da sie haben euch hier belogen
deshalb darf man ihn auch an anderer
stelle nicht glauben das ist ein
erhebliches problem für die
demokratischen kräfte im land
und damit sind wir bei tina hildebrandt
es gab eine einigermaßen lausige
impfkampagne kann man sorgen jetzt
werden die bürger verpflichtet frau
hildebrandt oder sollen verpflichtet
werden und es kann immer noch nicht ein
präzises ziel ausgerufen werden wir
wissen ja auch wirklich noch nicht wann
diese pandemie zu ende ist ja das
scheint mir ein bisschen das problem das
ist auch das was frau prise man ja
beschreibt dass sie also modellieren
kann unter welchen umständen welche
szenarien eintreffen aber ich finde das
ist dass die debatte komme mir
wahnsinnig kleinteilig teilweise vor
dann sollen wir nach fünf monaten impfen
oder nach sechs das sind alles fragen
die man sich medizinisch beantworten
kann und dann wird das so gemacht aber
ich finde das was verloren gegangen ist
in der politik und das wäre für meine
begriffe auch die aufgabe der neuen
regierung ist im grunde eben die ziele
zu beschreiben und nicht nur zu erklären
sondern auch zu begründen das ist ein
unterschied also wir haben eine
bundeskanzlerin gehabt wo dann alle sehr
froh waren dass sie das alles so gut
versteht und sie hat sich dann eine
zeitlang da als oberste pandemie
erklären betätigt aber eine pandemie
erklären ist was anderes als eine
politik begründen und dazu müsste man
glaube ich genau das machen was frau
prise man auch sagt man müsste einfach
einmal definieren was sind unsere ziele
sind unsere instrumente und wie kommen
wir da hin und das würde ich mir von der
neuen regierung wünschen dass sie das
macht denn das ist das was im lauf
dieser pandemie immer mehr auf der
strecke geblieben ist eine die bhu sagt
eine impfpflicht frau strack zimmermann
ist das absolut letzte mittel
interessanterweise das absolut letzte
mittel zu dem wir greifen sollen haben
wir alle anderen mittel schon geprüft
und müssen jetzt einfach zu diesem
letzten mittel greifen naja ich sagte ja
vorhin
dass das ein mittel ist zudem keiner
gerne greift aber dass die situation
offensichtlich so ist und es wird ja in
den fraktionen auch darüber diskutiert
das ist übrigens nicht partei abhängig
sondern durchaus innerhalb der parteien
auch läuft eine diskussion das ist auch
gut so
wie gesagt ich bin keine
wissenschaftlerin und wenn man uns jetzt
hier zuhört und sie erklären
verschiedene varianten und verschiedene
möglichkeiten könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass der ein oder andere in der republik
abschaltet weil er sagt jetzt verstehe
ich nur noch bahnhof das ist ja auch
sehr abstrakt und schwierig lauter
schlauer bürger sollte man die hand nur
schlaue bürger aber ja wir haben in der
tat mehr schlaue bürger als weniger
schlauer denn die anzahl derer die sich
impfen gelassen haben und auch impfen
lassen sind ja deutlich in der mehrheit
ist darf man ja nicht vergessen diese
bilder die sie gerade gezeigt haben
vermitteln das gefühl
dass hier millionen auf der straße sind
so ist es nicht ich glaube auch dass die
diese grad gezeigt haben dann bin ich
gesagt hier aus millionen nein nein aber
man könnte den eindruck bekommen
in der in der darstellung was ich damit
sagen will wir werden auch viele nicht
mehr erreichen auch mit kampagnen und
ich glaube in der tat dass neben der
diskussion im pflicht ich mir immer
wünschen würde dass wir die
kommunikationswege neben dem klassischen
fernsehen neben den plakaten das auch
immer dass wir lernen auch mal in diese
kanäle reinzugehen facebook instagram
was auch immer es gibt irgendwelche
influenza die machen werbung für
lippenstift oder für irgendeinen tralala
millionen von followern warum holt man
sich nicht die und sagt du kannst gerne
bei einer werbung für einen lippenstift
machen aber jetzt macht mal werbung in
deine zielgruppe sich impfen zu lassen
das kann man alles machen und ich glaube
und da bin ich auch optimistisch dass
wir als neue bundesregierung genau
diesen weg gehen so wie es übrigens auch
in den 80er jahren als aids zum ersten
mal auftauchte durch eine kampagne
zugegeben da gab es keine sozialen
netzwerke man eben gesagt hat wir müssen
die menschen erreichen die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht kommt sagt frau
stark zimmermann die kommt die
einrichtung bezogen eingesetzt die wir
morgen beschließen und meiner fragen bei
der fdp
nein das ist wenn sie mir erlauben das
ist deswegen von relevanz es geht ja gar
nicht nur um pflegepersonal es geht
darum dass in ein haus am sollen alle
gruppen sind also ältere merlin ganze
einrichtung über kommt eben da kommt der
der koch da kommt der der reiniger dass
alle die einen fuß reinsetzen nachweisen
müssen dass sie geimpft sind um nur eine
rolle zusätzlich persönlich ich weiß das
kann man auch anders sehen finde das
völlig richtig denn wir sind in der
verantwortung auch in freiheit in der
verantwortung gerade für die die sich
nicht schützen impfpflicht allgemeine
impfpflicht herren es ja oder nein
moment entsteht der eindruck vor dass
die frage die antwort auf diese frage im
pflicht ja oder nein an umfragen
festgemacht wird oder an der frage wie
viele sind schon geimpft als noch
weniger geimpft waren waren wir dagegen
jetzt wo viele geimpft sind sind wir
dafür und das macht wenn man vom ende
her denken fatales gefühl bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger nämlich belogen
worden zu sein wir müssen darüber reden
dass es am anfang schlichtweg nicht
verhältnismäßig gewesen wäre eine
impfpflicht zu machen es wäre eben nicht
die ultima ratio gewesen damals hatten
wir chancen ist noch besser hinzukriegen
ob das jetzt mit influence dann klappt
oder ob das durch niedrigschwellige
impfkampagnen klappt fakt ist wir haben
vertrauen verloren auf dem weg wir
verlieren jetzt nochmal vertrauen
deswegen bin ich sehr dafür dass wir die
frage der impfpflicht sehr
sachorientiert im bundestag diskutieren
das abstimmung freigegeben werden das
ist grundsatzdebatten sind dass es auch
ein stückweit ergebnisoffen ist weil
viele fragen offen sind was wollen wir
erreichen mit der impfpflicht wollen wir
90 prozent durch impfung erreichen
wollen wir eine durchimpfung von 99
prozent bei über 55 jährigen erreichen
wie wollen wir sanktionieren weil ich
glaube die frage im pflichtbereich
impfzwang ich glaube das würde niemand
das sanktioniert es wird nur so gehen
dass man das ähnlich wie bei der masern
im pflicht eben auch mit bußgeldern
belegt und ich halte es für wichtig dass
man zusätzlich zur debatte im bundestag
eben auch den ethikrat nochmal
hinzuzieht wir müssen diese debatte
breiter aufstellen sonst wird es
wirklich schwierig der ethikrat soll das
bis ende des jahres müssen auch bereit
sein die debatten auf der straße zu
ertragen und daneben auch da
entsprechende antwort darauf zu geben
wir können doch nicht akzeptiert das
gegen recht verstoßen wird in dieser
form wie wir das sehen ich habe vorher
stand in saarbrücken auch eine
versammlung auflösen lassen wogegen wir
keine vorschriften verstoßen worden ist
dann müssen wir auch sehr deutlich
machen dass das mit dem rechtsstaat
nicht zu bereinigen werden das muss
vorbereitet so den minister ministerin
vor der an privathäusern aufbauen das
ist nicht tolerabel und da muss auch
entsprechend der rechtsstaat
durchgreifen bei aller unterschiedlichen
diskussion es muss auch leute geben
dürfen die völlig anderer meinung sind
aber das ist eine übergriffige kite die
wir in keiner form durch ein dekret ba
hat letzte woche telegramm hier notiert
gesagt das ist ein medium ein kanal auf
dem tatsächlich nicht nur gegen ihn
persönlich morddrohungen ausgesprochen
worden sondern sich 80.000 menschen
unkontrolliert verabreden zu genau
diesen demonstrationen hat die fdp sich
dazu schon eine haltung erarbeitet wie
man dafür sorgt dass auch da eine
verantwortung der betreiber plötzlich
organisiert wird durch den staat na ja
sie können natürlich nicht verhindern
dass sich leute organisieren die könnten
sich auch positiv organisieren wenn sie
so sie können hat man kann ja keine
qualitätskontrolle sondern die tatsache
ist wenn menschen sich organisieren und
objektiv strafrechtlich relevante dinge
machen da dass man das sich nicht
gefallen lassen kann und da geht es um
eine minderheit die ich hab das neulich
das wort terrorisieren in den mund
genommen die die mehrheit terrorisiert
da habe ich briefe bekommen das will ich
hier gar nicht noch mal wiederholen
aber es waren einige dabei die haben
ihren klarnamen darunter gesetzt die ich
angerufen habe die natürlich verstört
waren als er mich wahrscheinlich haben
die gedacht sein telefonjoker oder so
ich habe mich bemüht man ins gespräch zu
kommen keine chance
wir sind da noch nicht am ende dieser
diskussion und trotzdem herr lauterbach
muss ich noch mal fragen nach
impfpflicht ausgerechnet in einer zeit
sie würde ja kommen im märz april also
ausgerechnet dann
wenn sich die welt um diesen angepassten
impfstoff bemüht und wenn es eigentlich
wieder darauf ankommt dass man mit viel
solidarität
dafür sorgt dass das jetzt nicht nur bei
uns im land möglich ist sondern auch in
anderen teilen der welt milliardenfach
dh wir würden eine impfpflicht
ausgerichtet dann ausrufen wenn wir noch
nicht mehr sicherstellen können dass und
in welcher anzahl der auch bei uns ist
das ist richtig aber trotzdem schulden
wir es unserer bevölkerung einen schutz
anzubieten so dass wir nicht von welle
zu welle weitergehen im verband hat
vollkommen zu recht also vorgetragen
dass wir unsere ziele benennen müssen
ihr könnt nicht nur über das reden was
wir machen die mittel sondern es sind
eigentlich die ziele und ich kann
einfach sagen was für mich ein wichtiges
ziel hier ist hätte ich sonst gefragt
das also frau briesemann spielfilme für
mich anfang an ein wichtiges ziel so
schnell wie möglich die bevölkerung so
gut zu immunisieren
dass wir die del-tabelle abschließen mit
möglichst wenigen toten dass wir die
mikrowelle wenn irgend möglich noch
vermeiden was das ist durchaus noch
nicht unmöglich und dass wir dann auch
einen guten schutz vor weiteren wellen
haben und diesen impfstoff müssen wir
vorab besorgen und zwar auf
sagen wir sogar mit auf reserve mit
vorräten wenn wir den impfstoff nicht
komplett brauchen dann können den immer
noch spenden keine frage aber der eben
stoff muss bezahlt werden besorgt werden
und zwar in eine menge dass wir auch
eine reserve haben es ist nicht
zuträglich dass wir sozusagen von woche
zu woche den impfstoff war so verteilt
den wir grad bekommen haben da müssen
wir serben da sind der impfstoff ist
mittlerweile das wissen viele nicht neun
monate ist der lagerbar
tiefgekühlt wir müssen den dämmstoff
beschaffen den wir brauchen und werden
wir ihn nicht mehr brauchen dann wird er
verschenkt gerne über kovacs aber das
ziel muss sein del tabelle runter
mikrowelle wenn möglich noch vermeiden
und dann werden noch andere werden kommt
dass wir die erst gar nicht aufkommen
lassen und das ist aus meiner sicht nur
möglich mit diesen zwei säulen booster
impfung und impfen so und jetzt auch in
konflikten pflege ich auch im krieg dann
müssen wir dann ich hatte ja aber sie
haben mich ja gerade eingespielt da sich
das dass ich glaube dass es erhebliche
widerstände
der punkt ist jetzt erreicht wir sind
jetzt regina so prekären lage auch mit
der ungesunden variante die die kinder
auch noch gefährden kann dass wir sagen
müssen okay dann muss der staat in
diesem konflikt gehen auseinander sicht
so die impfpflicht wird kommen die frage
ist wie sie ausgestaltet wird und wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wenn die
impfpflicht dann da ist auch für die
personen die wir betrachten wollen
genügend im frühjahr sonst scheitert und
wir müssen natürlich genauso überlegen
wie man tatsächlich schafft an die
ungeimpften hand zu kommen wir haben ja
nicht mal ein freak esther das fordern
jetzt die kommunen österreich geht da
mit entsprechendem beispiel voran wie
kommt man dann ganz praktisch an die
ungeimpften also wir könnten sehr viel
mehr tun und wir können im übrigen auf
basis unserer jetzigen impf daten glaube
ich schon sehr viel mehr sehen wo die
gegenden sind wo zu wenig menschen
geimpft sind deswegen ist das zumindest
man für das saarland mit 73,6 prozent
impfquote mit dass höchstens hier in
deutschland haben jetzt mein ansatz zu
erreichen dort auch noch mehr zu impfen
also mein mein ansporn ist bevor die
impfpflicht greift vielleicht im
april/mai dann auch wirklich die
menschen schon geimpft zu haben das
kriegt man hin wenn man vor ort das mit
mobilen teams wir haben im sommer wo
alle immer sagen die politik hat nichts
gemacht haben wir mit mobilen teams fünf
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft in
niedrigschwellige angebote gemacht und
darauf kommt es natürlich auch jetzt
wieder an ich glaube jetzt ist der
zuschuss der impfstoff zu den leuten und
nicht die leute zu dem stoff und es gibt
ganz tolle modelle in bahnhöfen
eigentlich holen universität überall wir
haben schon vor einem jahr in amerika
oder auch davor den möbelhäusern geredet
richtig oder vor dem drugstore viola
prise mann michael meyer hermann und
brockmann wurden am samstag in der bild
zeitung als lockdown macher
angeprangert das haben wir hier auch
noch mal im bild
es ist zu sehen ich hoffe jetzt auch für
unsere zuschauer
wissenschafts verbände haben herr
lauterbach da sofort protestiert und
haben sich schützend vor die kollegen
geworfen müsste das nicht auch die
politik tun hätte sich nicht also sie
haben personenschützer beide hätten
nicht auch die politik sofort sagen
müssen solche angriffe gegen
wissenschaftler sind zu
kritisieren natürlich das ist ja auch
geschehen und ich habe mich ja selbst
auch in dieser debatte eingebracht
wieder über die details nicht also
berichten aber es ist auf jeden fall so
dass also ich mit dazu beigetragen habe
dass der bild zeitung diese also
also diese artikel entfernt wurde wofür
ich auch dankbar war dass das passiert
was also spät gewesen aber immerhin man
hat er reagiert aber da habe ich mich
auch selbst in der vielleicht noch gar
nicht minister aber ich will ja ich
sozusagen selbst angesprochen gefühlt
weil ich war ja teil des teams meister
also gearbeitet hat dann kann ich eben
dann kann ich besser herrn hans fragen
warum hat die politik nicht sich sofort
vor diese wissenschaftler gestellt also
ich halte das für ganz entscheidend dass
man sich vor die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler stellt und ich sage
das auch noch mal in aller
öffentlichkeit nicht die wissenschaft
macht entscheidungen sondern wir als
politiker treffen die entscheidung und
wir übernehmen die verantwortung jeden
locker und den es im saarland gegeben
hat habe ich an erster stelle zu
verantworten die erleichterungen die
lockerungen habe ich zu verantworten und
die wissenschaft kann bestenfalls hier
begleiten und beraten und das haben wir
auch immer transparent gemacht die
politische entscheidung obliegt den
gewählten vertretern die wissenschaft
berät sie informiert in der
öffentlichkeit wir sind das land der
wissenschaft und deswegen ist für mich
dieser fall ein fall für den presserat
ich kann das so nicht stehen lassen und
das sage ich auch über das ist frau
prise man auf ihrem twitter-account los
in ihrem mail account los nach einem
solchen nach einer solchen
berichterstattung
so ein vorfall ist natürlich bitter vor
allen dingen weil irgendwie ein paar
tage vorher genau dieselbe zeitung
geschrieben hat wir brauchen oder wie
können wir einen locker und vermeiden
also da sieht man dass dieser
widerspruch massiv ist der in diesen
titels heilen in den schlagzeilen der
widerspruch ist in den schlagzeilen und
der ist nicht aus der wissenschaft das
einfach eine nicht korrekte darstellung
und diese nicht korrekten darstellungen
das ist etwas was natürlich viele
menschen bemerken das bemerken die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
sofort ich habe nicht von der
bildzeitung mitbekommen dass so was
geschrieben wird sodann von den kollegen
und kolleginnen die mich angerufen haben
haben wir gesagt haben hey das läuft ja
gerade total falsch und wir stehen
natürlich total hinter die die max
planck gesellschaft die
wissenschaftsorganisation die haben sich
alle wirklich klar hinter uns gestellt
und das hat mich sehr gefreut und das
ist ja nicht nur ein angriff auf mich
dass es ja auch ein angriff auf die
gesamte wissenschaft das versucht die
glaubwürdigkeit und das vertrauen in die
wissenschaft zu reduzieren und das ist
schwierig denn wir werden viele krisen
noch haben in denen wir das vertrauen in
die wissenschaft brauchen und wenn das
durch solche wirklich widersprüchlichen
und auch nicht konsistenten nachrichten
in dem fall kann man sogar seinen
falschen nachrichten
und terminiert wird dann ist die frage
wie machen wir beim klima waren dabei
wirklich schwierigeren probleme als
omikron und älter wie machen wir da
weiter wenn wir uns da auch die
wissenschaftlich verlassen können in der
stelle wirklich auch ein danke an das
team von mir die sind wahnsinnig
unterstützen dort gewesen und auch
[Musik]
danke an das team auf jeden fall wie
können sie unter diesem druck arbeiten
ja man gewöhnt sich so ein bisschen aber
ich verstehe natürlich auch gut dass
viele meiner kolleginnen und kollegen
exzellente wissenschaft machen aber
niemals in der talkshow wie hier kommen
würden ich bin auch total froh dass ich
hier so ein bisschen mit der schalter
auf abstand bin und ich freue mich auch
auf januar ich werde wieder presse pause
machen so nenne ich das sonst komme ich
auch selber gar nicht zum forschen ich
versuche immer so ein stückchen
natürlich öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu
machen weil es total wichtig ist aber
ich mache dann auch wieder über monate
typischerweise pause wo ich mich auf die
vorstandsarbeit konzentriert darauf
freue ich mich gerade riesig wir hätten
sie total gerne hier in der runde um das
noch mal zu sagen frau hildebrandt wie
sehr müssen eigentlich auch journalisten
kollegen protestieren und sich
beschweren
jetzt erst einmal ein bisschen blöd über
kollegen irgendwie zu reden aber ich
glaube das was da passt was bild da
gemacht hat ist wirklich ein
gefährliches spiel in so einer lage weil
das das ist ja keine berichterstattung
oder keine aufklärung es ist im grunde
eine schuldzuweisung die die öffentlich
gemacht wird was ich aber extrem
unglücklich finde ist dass eine
regierung die antritt und sich eines
neuen stils ruhm den sie in teilen sich
auch durchgezogen hat sich dann in bei
dieser zeitung auf einer party zeigen
und es ist eines der ersten bilder dass
von dieser regierung auch entstanden ist
und das ist glaube ich auch keine gute
art und weise dann sowas zurückzuweisen
oder bahn konterkariert damit natürlich
auch direkt wieder regen einfach mal
sagen hey leute aber ich war nicht beide
party